it's me markiplier
you know you know it's me
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to amnesia rebirth
this is a bit of a surprise this game
was announced just about a month ago and
it came out and i kind of forgot that it
was coming out today and yes this
is the sequel or prequel to amnesia
the dark descent made by frictional
games not the chinese room like amnesia
machine for pigs
i didn't do any of the settings
shoot this game should not be played to
win
immerse yourself in the world in the
story
fear and darkness are your enemies okay
sure kind of an egyptian alien thing
going on here it is
uh exciting i actually don't know how to
feel and these are the dark descent was
my first
moment i wish i could see something no
stop
shut up shut up shut up here we go
okay now you may speak pain has made of
you
in hiding curled in on yourself
unable to show the world your face
[Music]
acting on instinct lashing out
even at those closest to you
[Music]
time has passed and time is a thief
it has stolen your memories
the agony has faded but
so has every precious moment of joy
you have been hollowed out from the
inside
and there's nothing left of the person
you used to be
but you try you try to remember how to
smile
you try to remember how to love
and one day you crawl out from your
hiding place and step
back into the world
[Music]
and then every day
you do what you must to survive
wow that's heavy that's real
heavy that oh i'm a drawn
okay beautiful
plane crashing coming nothing don't
worry
pretending it's not there won't make it
go away
it's just turbulence it'll settle down
soon
yes yes i know it's hard though your
head tells you one thing but your heart
disagrees
try to sleep i couldn't i keep imagining
what might go wrong
i know someone who can help you and
who's that
oh i had no idea i didn't want him to be
lonely
i know my heart it's good for him to
have an adventure but
he'll be glad when this journey's over i
think he's
had a hard life and there's so much more
to come
alex
okay
well i called it
plane crash am i the only survivor this
is like the beginning to the
forest also i am not going to judge
forget
don't lose it no no come on
need to find him he must understand
i am still jesse
okay whatever you say
i'm fighting it i what happens if i
don't fight it
i mean i didn't really fight it
apparently i fought it i'm just so
strong of will
so powerful don't forget
don't lose yourself low down in them
maybe this summer finally pronounced it
correctly loud down them
oh loud down he do ah i
there's no way i'm going to pronounce
this girl
i have rotten it will help
but you must try to keep calm or it will
get worse
do not allow yourself anger do not allow
yourself to fear
you understand me tassie
okay might be a bit of a problem
depending on what happens
thank you
good question where
and what i was trying to say before i
was i'm not going to judge celine for
having a toy monkey
that's totally fine oh i have to
remember she will die
find salim okay
interesting oh oh
what are these like all my memories wait
a minute
okay let's back up a step back up a step
let's not go too deep forward there will
be a time
to think about this all kinds of deeply
later
in my handwriting my handwriting you
don't remember the big ass
plane crash that just happened because
that kind of just happened
move around oh it's so cool to be back
in amnesia again
and it's so cool to see that they it
looks like they updated the engine quite
a bit
this looks lovely i can't wait to see
some custom stories
although i was like hoping for custom
stories out of um
shoma
that's the doctor i'm here i'm here
i'm here i'm here hello
is anyone hello i'm here i guess that's
not gonna work
or do this something about this make
sure no one steals the plain while i'm
out let's put that on the wheel there
could clunky clunk
[Music]
did i do it wrong okay there was a
handle somewhere
tab open inventory oh it's a handle
i will try again oh
ah wait what's that on my wrist
kinda looks like it might be an alien
artifact
it's white okay
i remember people were
hurt in the crash i was here
i think where how could
where did they go how could you have
been here
how could you have known that but also
just woken up from that
unless you thought we'll get you up
[Music]
hmm yeah something don't add up seems
like maybe we survived the crash and
already went away but for some reason i
came back
hi bird
[Music]
leon jonathan give us a hand here
what is slapping in my ears
what is scooching around all deep in my
brain
i don't like that we have no choice we
need to get them to shelter i know
it's sunny he's hurt you know what he's
like
let's get him down there then you and i
can sit on him while the dog takes a
look don't worry
the caves aren't far good thanks hank
thank you hanku caves
okay caves
uh-huh oh
how do i rotate again r e it told me and
i've completely forgotten how to rotate
nope okay whatever it'll remind me later
maybe
i don't know hello well considering that
i've probably already been through this
and i have some sort of
amnesia i'm guessing what is it my ears
what is the slapping it sure ain't sand
i don't know what sand sounds like it
don't sound like that
salim are you there
are you there salim saleem okay at least
the
slapping has gone out of my ears i still
don't know what the thing is on my wrist
it's probably not important probably
some
whoa hey yeah yeah crush you eat food
yum no it's back again maybe backwards
progress doesn't i don't know
it just wants to be all gucci that's
fine
it will goosh as it desires to goosh
well
seems like i'm gonna die out here
quick and do a game but you know a good
experience all around
hello hi oh that looks interesting
hello
but it's good isn't it people have been
here
so we'll be shot with salt
instead of dying first i guess
what now getting your hypes up
we're in this [ __ ] why is it saying
gamepad was disconnected
please reconnect i don't need to
reconnect it i'm not using the bad i'm
using a mouse and keyboard thank you
oh that stopped finally hello
anything no is there a point to opening
these ooh there is
postcard susan dearest alfie stories
don't do this place justice it is
amazing you've never seen anywhere as
busy as the market in algiers the smells
the flavors the colors and all the noise
i may have picked you both up a little
something you never know you luck all my
love
always dad oh dad oh
that's sweet dad oh that's good who's
there my dad
my dad my dad might be my dad is that my
dad
oh tazzy look at the hands
such tiny perfect fingers
hello hello my little one
well that's nice that's really nice
it's not quite the horrific memories
that were in the original amnesia but
i'm sure that it'll get there
definitely it's all right i can manage
come on not far now
hello is anyone there salim
count him more tightly or the stitching
will tear i
am sorry i will be still
so clearly they're not setting up to be
a twist that oh i've been here before
because it's so obvious
so what is the twist that they're
looking at
look at us look at us love transcends
law look at us look at us
i i had something to say to you
whole speech something poetic but you
don't need to say anything
i know it's just i never thought this
would happen
any of this you and me i would never
imagine
there is no one i would rather spend my
time with
really really stop worrying i'm in love
with you you idiot
you are my heart
i said no poetry
that's really sweet i have a funny
feeling that saleem is dead
yeah oh a map okay that's good we're
somewhere in
audra hara ahne delta
plateau da hagare
somewhere in there probably people are
going to find us
okay james expedition leader
that says salim is alive apparently
maybe the pilot's dead and rachel holt
is apparently dead that is an excellent
question where did they all go
i have lighters i have card
okay anastasia trianon is that me tazzy
yeah probably engineer drafter paper's
not named french national le bourget
as it does you really don't know how to
best handle this crucial cop in the
field this is not a difficult trip we've
been on much worse
last year has been hell for her that
call from paris she sounded so broken
i guess all i can do is look out for her
try to keep her busy need to prod malik
and rachel to do the same
she's got salem here too which will help
i really really hope this is what she
needs
that it can start mending things for her
for both of them
hey i promise i won't bring this up
again but
i know this won't be easy on you first
time out again you know
so if you want a break you want to get
away from people any of them
just say whatever you need so their
daughter
those who follow i am salim hanachi i
crashed with the crew of the cassandra
on march
3rd 1937. i
and others were injured we stayed while
the rest of the crew went for help
my companions are dead now and the radio
is broken
i cannot wait alone there is some sort
of creature here
i must go after the crew as best i can
they followed the path through the
mountain
i will leave signs tazzy if i do not
find you
and by some chance you are reading this
know that you are my heart
why couldn't you wait i'll find you
i promise
i'm more concerned about the some sort
of creature thing that seems to be more
the more imminently thing in the fact
that everyone else is dead
it seems to be uh my darling amanda by
now you'll know about the crash
and you'll know that our situation is a
bit sticky
we're off for a walk through the desert
to see if we can find a radio or
a village or some other sort of help
everyone's putting a brave face on it
but no one really knows what's going to
happen so maybe this is it
maybe this is the last you'll hear if it
is i'm sorry my love up
i suppose it's my fault for wanting a
big adventure i should have stayed home
after all
please tell him both that i love him
tell susan that she's
the best girl in the world and tell
alfie to look after her sister
oh now i'm sitting here with tears and
behind me
hands are trembling you know i just
don't know what right
i don't know how to say goodbye i can't
believe
this is goodbye i love you my darling
girl
i know in my heart we'll see each other
again even if it's not in this life
you're jonathan that's really sad
i'm very sad yasmine chobani
id card what a beautiful girl
is that your daughter yes
my father keeps nagging me for
grandchildren
did you leave her in paris yes
is she with her gran yasmin i'd like to
check the sadio samples are packed up
give me a hand of course mr mitchell
sorry hank
boy this is just a trip down horrible
memory lane
wow okay i'll throw that didn't want to
even go near that
yeah the memories some memories i just
don't want you know
some memories just can't have hmm
i don't know what this is i don't know
it's a mine
more matches photo wow
i don't like their faces what's wrong
with their faces ooh
that's no good all right memory i won't
stay here
there's something in the tunnels i swear
to god
you'll be with us and i'll take care of
you
come here
well these memories sure are exploding
back into my brain
sure it's fine okay i looked at all this
i think i looked it up
never oh no
are you okay
salim i'm sorry oh that lucas i cannot
bear it
the rest of you this is not salim's
fault
i am of sound mind never written
okay just
oh never mind
i can't read this it's in some strange
language
god look at that cursive it's beautiful
um i know him you guess
i think yeah well
let's just move on from that
let's go further into this hell hole
what's this what's in here what's in
this hell hole
what kind of hell hole we dealing with
okay the goopy hell hole
oh that is definitely good
that's definitely good oh
i hate that i went to see mossio
esperando at the market but he has no
more work until next week i know that
tazi has savings and i know that
something will come but
it is hard it is not just two of us now
i want to know that i am keeping them
safe
kind of looks like the beginning of
amnesia the dark descent huh
kind of looks a little bit like that you
see you see what i'm saying there you
see
i don't want to go in there all right
well looking like
i'm going down here i don't need the
wind particles blasting into my face
i'm not sure this is the best idea yeah
well you know
this kind of the game right
good stuff oh it's a beetle
[Music]
okay staying in the dark without a light
source will increase my fear
do i have a fear meter
something yeah if only i had a lantern
that'd be
that'd be something special why
what who are we thinking why are we
thanking them
i'm scared i'm scared i'm not scared i'm
brave
big brave man also why is there wind
down in the tunnels here
yeah looking at this statue i'm gonna
call it a statue
i like your triangle boobs that's really
nice hello
ah oh pillow all right
would you like a bowl thank you
that's a thing holy mother hear my plea
i can't really read the rest of that
oh there's stuff in these things
time to go pillaging time to destroy why
oh
no there's a latch on that reminds me of
somewhere else
i'm gonna have to hide this a bit like
the shrine
probably nothing probably definitely
probably definitely nothing probably a
whole lot of nothing
yeah me too hope i can find that yeah
that'd be great
a letter came from hank mitchell he
offers her work
journey to french sudan i pray that she
will take it
it is what she needs what both of us
need to be away from
these memories and back into the world
yeah
well what was that
well it's a good question what was that
well this looks rickety
yeah probably not a problem
i'm always careful my night vision would
sure be useful right about now thank you
all right
i had a funny feeling that would happen
oh i'm about to die
ah there i go i'm struggling
[Music]
i'm struggling i'm struggling i'm
struggling
[Music]
that's a good question also where am i
also what is that oh those are big
bones there's a goop in my ears
disturbing sights and darkness will
increase your fear don't let it rise too
high
i'll try not to oh my god
great i love
squeeze holes oh
now yeah
no no no no no ah there we go
okay well
[Music]
wow
wow
good stuff what the hell is wrong with
me
seems fine to me seems like a whole lot
of nothing
seems like i need to get ahold of myself
how does that get here
that's a good question how did i get
here what did i do what did i do
i don't know seems like this whole
amnesia thing
is really coming to a head the pain
what pain oh that's weird
uh yeah that's
normal yeah that's normal
oh yeah that's definitely normal
[Music]
uh-huh i'm crouching
kind of looks like a face but that's
okay so apparently if i hold crouch i
can go all the way to the floor
that's good to know
i was wondering about that what exactly
is it
i don't remember
uh-huh oh
strange
oh oh
i'm magic
i'm a wizard
i'm a sorcerer you don't like this i
love this
[Music]
dude i got magical powers dude
i got magical powers what are you gonna
whoa
all right nothing all right bowl of
something whoops all right
that's fine hey how are you doing
christ's name how could i leave him
i know i know it makes sense everything
he said but
i did such stupid [ __ ]
self-sacrificing [ __ ]
listen i know celine and i know you
i know what you're capable of he'll make
it
and you'll get back to him even if all
hell stands in your way
i know well it sure seems like all of
hell is standing in my way
well this is going greenish
[Music]
close your eyes for sleep is coming
hush now lullaby
papa's here so don't you cry
sleep well alice alice has some
flowers grown out of her head oh this is
fine
oh this is very very fun everything is
as it seems to be and uh saleem and i
we're about to be
someone's been here yeah true no anyone
hello hello
how are you i found you first
i was able to meet them in the park this
afternoon after talking to the factory
manager at dinar
a proud moment alice has learned to
count to three with her blocks
wow why are these strewn about everyone
she did
[Music]
what happens if i close it while i'm
inside
nothing wow can i oh i can't go that way
well i'm in here so that's a thing am i
supposed to get the glow
am i supposed to get the the glow shroom
am i supposed to jump through the gap
whatever this is some alien mumbo jumbo
if i ever saw it
i don't know what this is all about
[Music]
whoa
almost alien it's so strange
all right cool
oh wow
well that's that didn't exactly go to
plan apparently i don't know how to use
my incredible powers just yet
hello hi how you doing
my name is markiplier i'm here to see
what the spooks are in this place
all right hello
hello
oh squeezy where does that lead
what is all that wait well hold on a
second wait
wait a minute wait a minute
wait hold on a minute
yeah look at this place
all right okay that's cool you know
totally cool
i'm down with this i'm into it
sure that's fine
sorry down there so what's with this
lady ooh
sorry i thought i saw something jiggling
in the distance i don't like
distance jiggling okay let's get this
out of here
seems like this place might be a little
bit unstable
that's fine hello lady
how are you doing hello baby
nice orb it's glowing again
well that's fascinating ooh a note
it's me nothing progresses time does not
change things light does not move across
the sky nor does it grow dimmer or
brighten and yet time must pass my mouth
is dry and i feel the pangs of hunger
wires know a predicted instability of
the flow of time around the junctions
between worlds where one step might
carry between
years but might preserve the body in its
current state or indeed
where the body changed but time did not
pass for the world around
is that what has happened is this whole
world frozen in a moment after its
destruction
how could i ever tell and what would it
change if i knew the answer
i'd given up on the attempt to find the
portal i have a notion that i could
apply wires predictions on the weakness
of the fabric between worlds
if only i could map them in some form oh
good
answers were between dimensions
great lovely place
truly something special okay so it's
kind of pointing in this
ow
i'm fine thanks
hi hey
why oh
oh oh hey um
you all right i'm defeated there's no
way back there's nowhere to go i have
searched for a portal but there is none
i have triangulated the weakest points
of levi's calculation but i cannot tear
a rift
for i do not have a traveler's amlin i
did not heed brennenberg's warning
yeah what choice did i have the shadow
sense the orb i had to risk all and step
through the portal
there is no water and no other means of
sustenance i will not live long
if you reader traveler from whatever
would you come
if you comprehend and if you know enough
to speak to those of the human world
called earth
let them know this i was the first to
solve the mysteries of the gate builders
i was the first human to breach the
boundaries between worlds
i professor fluensten
lois herbert of cambridge england was
the first
god forgive me and also god praise me
i'm amazing in every way look at me
and weep there are shadows of the dead
in the ruins
those who lived here were human or near
it so perhaps this was
zenzu after all on eden or some other
stronghold of humanity but whatever this
place once was it
shot turned these must have been the
gate builders but what horror could
cause such destruction
surely even the shadow cannot destroy a
whole world there is no sign of a portal
even if i were to find one the orb was
lost to the shadows and i do not have
another there is something else here
stirring in the fog i see bright lights
as it hunts and here it's cries
i do not think it is alive well just
because it's not alive doesn't mean it
can't kill you
see weak points but no amulet you mean
this amulet
idiot not so good now a herb okay
goodbye
see you around later nerds
i'm going over here now wherever here
is wherever i am
fun place okay so something over here
definitely something
what do we what is this hello
hello oh
okay
dusty here it could do with an air
purifier
almost like i got this compass hey shush
your mouth and let me do
the guiding and we'll get somewhere okay
don't need your doubts
what was that
it is working levi's calculation applied
the measurements clearly show variance
as if there are great
centers of attraction which draw all
towards them but these must be the weak
points that were spoke of
i have identified two good candidates
and one excellent but i have no means to
proceed
travel is amulet according to wire
should focus these energies and provoke
the weak points to tear open
forming a rift between this world and
another but i have no amulet if i
remember his treaties rifts can form
without an amulet
but that is down to the alignment of the
spheres and their stars
i cannot move the stars i will find some
way
i must if you've added you'll die
i guess that's promising yeah
cool man it was really loud then oh
oh i'm still here
[Applause]
what the hell is that
oh being noticed huh
what exactly am i going to be noticed by
oh
okay something over there i don't know
if they're just joking with me or if
there's actually something over there
is that a thing or is that a statue of a
thing is that a thing or a statue of a
thing is that a statue of a thing is
that a statue of thing that's the statue
of a thing
hey i
[Music]
christ yeah probably
hello hi your no one looks so good
well you you can only hope
this is all going swell
oh yeah that's a good oh
what where why ow oh is that a thing
i feel like i'm just missing huge parts
of this game i feel like i'm
almost skipping over it but i guess i
guess any progress forward is good
progress
i don't think i'm 100 all the
collectibles in this time
oh hello
ah okay i don't need that tell me i go
towards the big blowy thing that seems
to be obvious
thick why thick why why feck
hi did you do something to all these
people
did you turn them into pillars of sand
why are they all running screaming
holding their eyes
that seems like a bad sign well this is
all
going super good this is just delightful
i don't see anything was there anything
actually over here was that just
he's goofing me is that an engine holy
crap
man i don't even know ah why am i
oh oh
ah gravity my i'm falling i fall catch
me
[Music]
you know which drawing i'm gonna go to
first damn
damn damn
well this is lovely monkey
oh alice wonderland
i i have to remember
yeah but do you even know what you're
trying to remember
notice of rejection rejection
for what what got rejected see i'm
willing to bet there's tons of things
that i'm overlooking
and i'm not even like rushing through
this i just feel like
the everything's just kind of all over
the place which is good
totally fine like i'm down with that
[Music]
ruining the emotional atmosphere of this
he how's it going
sleep baby
oh my god your face no no no
that's not good
baby
oh
baby
look at that baby that's a big baby that
baby's getting bigger
that's a big baby
well this is all setting up for
emotional heartbreak very quickly
i'm pretty sure it seems to be the
general
like direction that we're headed in
no it's but it's so real
yeah i'm guessing there's something
about this alien dimensional technology
that allows you to enter the world of
dreams and a message of the mind
something's different
i feel like i don't fit my body i feel
like i don't fit my body the hell i'm
heavy
oh my god it feels like oh
god do i have a belly now or something
do i got a belly that i didn't have
before do i have a belly
i can't tell i wasn't really paying
attention before
hello darkness my old friend
i've come to see you again
i know i know i know i know
oh my god why would you do that to me
why would you do that
why would you do that that's baloney
bloney is my first name
yeah that's what the doctor ordered
oh i don't like that it looks like my
creature from that evolution game oh i
don't like them
well that's not good
[Music]
okay this is growing great
yeah maybe it wasn't maybe there's a
giant baby floating out into the nowhere
yeah you know i don't feel too good
either
[Music]
man i wish i had a lantern
lantern would be lovely
how can you tell it's hot up there how
can you tell that
i hate this i really hate it well i'm
not a fan
either so let's just get through it okay
oh well that that's dumb all right well
if the matches aren't going to do me any
good i'm going to try not to waste them
hello this would have been easy to miss
saleem good to have celine back with
this desire
circumstances been a rough year
okay oh here we go
hey don't look at me like that i get it
i really do
just surprisingly took you so long to
realize it
well you know denial is a strong emotion
what is the cans what cans there
i guess i should be more concerned why i
hold the bones and goopiness is there
but you know i'm worried about the cans
that's littering
can't have littering in a place like
this it's a historical simpsons this is
preserving
you know what i mean yeah you know what
i mean all right cool
this weapon can i use this
footy steppies
he was here
oh my heart what is it elise
at least we have a sister i'm pregnant
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i remember
i'm pregnant oh whoa
[Music]
whoa okay in paris
i'm gonna have a baby christ
you're gonna have a baby
where did you go live look what you did
to me your bastard you get back here
you take responsibility for what you did
where are you sleep salim
i got a funny feeling that some of these
memories probably ain't quite true
a weird disconnect about being heavier
and not whoa
same no no no no please
send him no please my love
i'm here i'm here now please stand stay
for me please
my hand heal my heart
what do i do what do i do now
who's supposed to find you
[Music]
this is sad moving any direction to
progress
not gonna tell me to press f to pay
respects oh
that's so sad oh
oh my god oh
oh so sad
i know i will not live it does not
hurt now i have lost you tazzy
it is only for a time i know
you will escape you carry something so
precious
live for us dazy live for the child live
and be free and one bright day we will
all
be together again know that you
are my heart well i'm sad now
oh my god that's terrible
i got a lantern now oh
look how fancy that is oh my god this is
so sad
what
[Applause]
i can't stand
yeah i'm sorry oh
boy oh boy
oh man yeah get away from the sadness i
guess
jeez
oh and i'm dead
and i've been crushed
okay oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] this i can't do this
not without you not without you
why did you have to go i don't know
why are you asking me i don't know
i pushed w as best as i could no
no no
live for our baby okay
oh my lantern's out of
juice
is someone there hello it's probably
good
oh what e money e money
that's my rapper name oh hello
[Music]
and i'm free well there's a baby on the
bottom right now
there's something going on here i think
that's her word for him
there's something going on here
something something weird's going on
with i got achievement widow oh freaking
great yeah that's the achievement i want
is what i want to remember i'm gonna pin
that in my refrigerator
yeah a widow oh good great
freaking fantastic go ahead call my mom
what in heaven said
look where we are what am i going to do
just look at me hold the extra check in
on your baby
hey baby how you doing how you doing
i can't believe i forgot this hey
but this isn't right is it i wasn't this
far gone
i i i wasn't even three months this
feels more than four
how that is wrong here
there's nothing i can do about it it's a
big baby that's that's what that's what
we were all knowing
if nothing else this is my reason to get
out of here
something's weird something's weird
something's weird like he said find the
others
something's weird something something
something's weird something's weird baby
a brother maybe
something's weird something's weird
where'd this baby come from was it
always there but i wasn't that far along
something's
weird
there was no mention of a baby before i
doubt that they would have allowed us to
go on an expedition if there was a baby
in the 1930s after all
some don't add up something's not right
here wait
the same fence no not the same fence
oh if i could just fall couldn't i
who me hobo hoomi hobo
all right cool see ya ah
my favorite brand or whatever the hell
that is love me a millet makazama
oh break out i'm just i'm about to die
all the time
that was my baby how's the adrenaline
kicking in
i know yeah why now yeah why now why now
is
strange i'm really thinking that there's
something deeper like this is an amnesia
game there's gonna be some
there's gonna be some weirdness going on
some twists some uncertainties
some mysterios some things that may not
seem what they are
is what they will be you know what i
mean oh hello
well this seems like an outpost out
thing it's not a friendliest surprises
count your lucky stars old chat you
could have come down in the middle of
nowhere
don't worry jonathan supplies water
a map there'll be something even if
there's no one home
michaels would have gathered the place
oh it's the pessimist day leon
more like dushan
[Applause]
oh okay
crunch yeah i'm down
get out of my way one i can't have this
i'm pregnant
hello wow look at her
all right i'm done looking at her hello
nope oh this looks puzzle-esque
i'm sure that i need to memorize this oh
it's in my brain
all right good got it yeah look at her
again all right wheel
[Music]
not sure why this was down if they were
already able to get through
here but whatever all right
see you're a [ __ ] it oh get out of my
way
and there was a thing where you know she
said she felt heavier
not like she belonged in her body all of
a sudden alien baby
alien baby alien baby
alien baby what's over here hello hi
and there hakeem recounted the tale of
the local tribe kalahanan they were too
reg
that refused to call to islam for their
own ancestor tin
heenan a bringer of healing and
fertility walked the sand and how should
they disbelieve the evidence of their
own eyes there was fighting as there
always is in such matters but the
kalhanon were hell wealthy and made
their peace through trade and salted
all right interesting hello
excuse me excuse excuse me ask you
excuse me sorry did this belong to
someone uh whatever
i doubt there's a reason oh there was a
reason
got it oh this goes nowhere but it does
it it doesn't
okay hello is there anything over here
you hear that baby it's not far
hush little baby don't you cry
i'm gonna get you some big pie
and you'll love to eat it too
then i'll have to go to the lou i don't
know whatever
i can't run maybe that's why
yeah probably normal hey there
baby did you see your light
i'm sure it gave you a fright oh my god
i hate lullaby mark
oh that's normal yeah okay that's
yeah mm-hmm uh-huh what's in god's name
maybe i should take an lsd
oh my god i gotta admit this is a
bizarre
opening to a game i'm not i'm not like
i'm playing it or i'm not talking bad
about it it's just it just
is it's a very strange opening to a game
it's clear that it wants me to get into
the emotions of it and i'm down with
that i'm down to clown i'm down i'm
super down but
man this is a trip
hello knock knock hi
precious tune and look at you look at
you
hey there baby i got achievement
i wish you were with me we were here
i i remember being scared why
yeah i don't know maybe the tank
look at the size of this place
okay yeah thanks for the input there
really appreciate
very helpful i can't carry any more of
those apparently
that's locked locked
oh yeah wow kabumi fascinating
why did they need to defend this so much
i i'm gonna blow you
away
that's fun that's fun there how you
can't shoot through here
you can't shoot it's all blocked up you
could well i guess it could make it
through there i
guess hello anybody home
i feel like i've been here before don't
know why but i have
oh that's the doctor the doctor
i'm on i'm not on the way am i on the
[Music]
way
i'm here i'll always be here
this baby sure sleeps a lot not sure how
much normal babies
sleep but is this where the doctor i
don't hear the doctor anymore
well oh yeah i was right
got to get to that radio yeah i'm
working on it okay oil can be used
why would i need to leave
trooper i suppose trouble with the
locals
could be bite marks too see
hyena maybe a damn big one
didn't finish its meal
uh multiple deaths
whoa
whoa i didn't mean to do that okay
request transfers should be brevis stop
account
okay shoot me delay unacceptable forward
immediately stop kept
okay
okay wow
this place kind of blows okay pressure
performance
urgent stop captain a le faire end
report death lee leggy do
stop suspect of insurgent stop ford on
combat alert stop
must report death leg and
desertion okay
i'll get to you keep talking please
don't stop
please don't stop there might be
something here
oh i can't oh what am i doing can i move
okay i can move
oh it seems to be much more important to
light candles
than it wasn't your first one not that
it was unimportant
but i didn't do it doctor where mets
here okay
so that doctor hold the dog yeah he
seems okay
between you and me i think he's the
drinker
maybe they sent him out here to dry out
uh-huh yeah well you know him being a
drinker is least of my concerns at the
moment
my main concerns being whatever the hell
is in this place with me
okay now we're getting more amnesia
now it's feeling like traditional
amnesia maman please
talk to pop before me please he has not
replied to my letters this is no place
for me the men are cruel and the land is
cruel i beg of you i beg of him i will
do anything everything to make amends if
he will not take pity ask
if he truly wants the family name to die
out here in the dust
meth sounds like we got a
whiner over here big baby
whiner big whining baby all right
why would i ever want to unlight it dust
desert aired plane i dream of you i call
your name
a flower blooms the petals fall sand
glass empties
still i call ten years gone my time
is done i journey home my battle's won
there's no one waiting no one there
just echoes and an empty
chair okay cool
man that was good stuff uh sad too
yeah sad definitely sad
uh okay well that just decided to go out
probably fine probably very fine
probably unbelievably fine
probably incredibly okay
why is everything locked
this looks valuable
that was supposed to break that's tough
dude
wow what happened
oh the power came on yeah i know how
that guy died
could chunk oh
i got a winch well that wasn't obvious
okay hello i
literally don't know how i'm making any
progress because i have no idea where
i'm going most of the time
damn it i've got to reach that radio
somehow yeah somehow
somehow somehow some way
a kitchen
[Music]
caught in a world where time
doesn't move and yet you carry on
[Music]
hmm whoa what was that
what was that i was having a revelation
whoa was that
whoa what did i just see what just
happened what's in these things
talk to me somebody please answer my
calls gin of the inner desert gathered
by
lulu
is a gene of calling okay that's great
really good stuff really good stuff
really good stuff
really great a ghoul that's really great
uh the ashen mother dejean of healing
that's great that is wonderful are these
important to know
are these part of a clue is this part of
like some puzzle i gotta
puzzle out probably hey what was that by
the way
uh-huh okay i'm still no closer to my
goal
i think hello
i need to get in there okay so there's
some place above
that i could definitely drop down
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah keep trying okay there's got to be
some way up above
that i can circle around that's
definitely a thing
i have a winch there was like an
elevator thing it was over here right
yeah somewhere over here ah oh it was
the clue to the thing i already knew
you think i don't know i already been
new pretty ah
well you know completionist wench blam
done wangling wangling
wangling i'm supposed to be going up
with that i
i think i'm supposed to be going up with
that oh
oh am i gonna rebuild this thing
oh
oh there we go
nice nailed it
i'm genius uh okay
hey come back here hey come back here
ain't afraid of you you're afraid of me
that's why you ran away
[ __ ] that's why you ran away
[ __ ] you wanna come show your face
around here
no you don't [ __ ]
what is this oh that's normal
i can't read this i hope this letter
finds you well we are now in the desert
proper and the heat is beyond belief
we've taken shelter in the courtyard of
ruined fortress until the sun is lower
there is nothing but desolation outside
mountainous crags amidst
endless waves of sand professor herbert
is certain he can find the root of the
tomb
although i cannot see how for the dunes
shift and change struck through i've
written on your behalf to father but i
do not think he will
i got a historian achievement look i'm
just trying to know what's going on man
i push you how are you doing baby
you liked how i pushed that thing i got
care give i got achievement i love
my baby even though i don't remember
having you where you came from i don't
care
so long as you stay out of my hair
love my baby gift that was scary
i love my baby i'm calling bumbo
it's my baby's bumbo they say how to
bumbo
fire bumbo fire mama load the cannon
bumbo loves to shoot the cannon don't
you bumbo
hey bumbo you wanna shoot the cannon
bumbo baby bumbo
baby bums a lot oh baby bumbo
oh man that guy got a face full of
cannon
oh that's not good
well probably fine bastards didn't die
look at this chap here suicide uh-huh
why would they do that
look what's this they drew straws
yeah okay what suicide by canon
oh i guess gun that makes sense
hello oh oh my god
oh my god
nope that'll hold it squeak
hello
something over here yasmin why is he
asman
paper's not our problem travel from not
our problem yes hospice for the plane
names of phases made clear she would
take him when come to me
could maybe help without help out with
tazzy
sure she's already figured out how to
manage sterling
fairchild even to freeze as a real way
with smiling and pretending she gives a
damn
i like him uh yeah me too man me too
the good captain he has to play the
fair-minded statesman pretend that kel
hanan
are more than savages give them the
benefit of the doubt he is and ass
that lot up a testament are worse than
the badoon
even the treg do not trust him i
remember the stories maxime told me they
skinned two of albert's troops
let them there die screaming salt rubbed
into their flesh all in the name of this
great
mother of theirs they put on pretty
smiles and give the captain painted
rocks
there's the worst of devils there aren't
so many slaughter them and make excuses
later if i were the commander
maybe we'll do it anyway yeah okay
okay i'm just trying to get to a
radio
okay
yeah working on it can i drop down here
am i up too high oh i'm sorry
am i up too high oh oh i'm sorry
oh i didn't realize i was up too high oh
i'm sorry i
over achieved oh oh
is my back
i hope the batteries don't run out okay
what did i just see by the way baby did
you see that
oh no it would hate for me to just
fall down that'd be the worst
to my destination
come on now wouldn't it be okay please
fell down
all right so what can i roll here that's
heavy hi
oh okay okay
well how about this cannon can i roll
the cannon just go roll this cannon out
here
oh yeah yeah how about this this looks
heavy
huh no i think i'm on the right track
right
raleigh oh this glued here they've done
this on purpose
they know what they're about oh my god
doc
i'm on getting to it hush
got to be something hefty
hey how you doing in here it's me
markiplier you know you know it's me
what [ __ ] god
fine you that was mean i don't mean
very mean very mean this
was that lamp oil large sure plopper in
uh deputation of the calanon further
complaints a bit over a little
apparently the man needs some activity
to keep them on you about afghan lords
start activation of the lower chambers a
man had broken through to the
underground chamber impressive
architecture rival to be cleared and
then the excavation of the site captain
of fuel
reports activity on the lower slope
speculates retaliation from the village
hard to believe guard doubled
delacroix wow absent sergeant fourier
believes them to be hiding in the
cistern capitaled found destroys in
cellar dead no sign of de la crosse
suspected argument x-axis no kidding
killing zertman incident sister and
legion
dugout killed men report animal attack
they're jumping at chatters every noise
hailed as lion or jackal
sergeant fourier suspects calendar
responsible fourth place on alert will
lead
search of cistern yeah i'm sure that
went well
i'm sure that went very well okay but
what am i supposed to do i need
something hefty
right why is this locked why have you
locked your door whoa
hey how you doing there whoa
hey oh how you doing oh hi
bonjour um oh bonjour
hey how are you doing am i supposed to
be doing something with this can i get
down here oh i fell
damn it that's not what i wanted i don't
think that's what i wanted ah i'm in the
genie room and back up i go okay
okay how about this barrel if i push
this one around
freaking oof man
oh yeah if i roll it that would be
easier
okay come on oh
oh oh oh my god why why why
why why why is it because i'm in the
dark
this really isn't that dark it's like in
between i see light right there it's not
a big deal
incoming
break all right well
oh hi
hello how are you
jump is this not right i feel
i feel like maybe i'm stupid
yeah i'm trying man guys i guess i'm
dumb i don't want to be dumb i don't
want to be dumb
i want to be smart
good cannonball what the hell are they
doing to me why are they just
messing with me are you just messing
with me
stop messing with me
oh this is open oh why why
stop i'm locking this lock
why is this open now this wasn't open
before was it oh no it was never mine
i'm dumb this was open
[Music]
what are you doing am i supposed to find
the wheels or something maybe oh
oh oh
oh that so my
don't fall don't fall don't fall my
first instinct was correct
okay so the yeah oh i needed the wheels
right
oh it makes so much sense now okay and
now
this makes sense this makes a lot of
sense this looks really make a lot of
sense too
i get it goodbye oh and there i go
almost dead
baby think about the baby well that's
not where i wanted you to break
i guess baby you proud of me hey baby
you proud of me
hello baby proud of me
oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
yeah someone didn't like him yeah that
that sounds about right yep
hello ding dong
hello hello doctor are you there hello
yes
yes i'm here eva is that you oh thank
god
it's tazzy does it
are you well yes well
no not really not at all i can't
remember
anything i'm pregnant i'm lost
send him a thought i'm in a fort
we were here before i think i don't know
doctor where are you we have found help
people a village
but yes me it's not well
before yes the fort
go through the mountain parts and it is
maybe an hour beyond there
the mountain bus yes yes i see the
village here
on the map oh thank god
but um doctor please there's something
else
i uh i keep blacking out
it feels like i'm losing control
i am aware of your recent problems
[Music]
of course the most important information
gets cut off right then and there
what else is new what else is new let me
glance at this
wow the town the doctor said it was
through the past yeah on the map
so i just need to find my way to that
okay
let's find a way to that let's do let's
make it happen you hear that baby
hear that baby i mustn't
get scared no if i get scared the baby
gets scared and then the baby don't know
to brave mama bear than i am
okay so that's gonna do it for this
episode uh this is fascinating
definitely different than i was
expecting amnesia to be uh but but it
seems like it's
it's going for the slow burn like really
like start to
build it up with like keeping the
monsters away at first and like uh
allowing you to just feel the world and
get immersed in the environment and i
really like that that's not bad
and my baby who's definitely not an
alien baby
yep but anyway so thank you everybody so
much for watching look forward to more
amnesia very soon
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]